people have been writing in saying David
you haven't been talking about the
YouTube advertiser boycott for a while
can you explain what's going on because
we're seeing ads on your YouTube videos
this is a tough thing Pat because I
don't want to just talk about the
YouTube advertiser boycott because in
the same way that with the Trump
administration when everything is a
scandal nothing is a scandal if the
YouTube ad boycott is a crisis every
single day it becomes background noise
and it also becomes fatiguing for the
audience so it's been a while now since
we've talked about the YouTube
advertiser boycott but I'll give you a
quick update okay if you don't know what
I'm talking about on March 31st YouTube
put in place a new algorithm to
determine when advertisements play
before YouTube videos that's how we make
money on YouTube when ads play before a
video of ours okay and on March 31st
when this new ad algorithm was turned on
in response to concerns from advertisers
about the algorithm not being strict
enough our YouTube revenue went down 99
plus percent it doesn't even matter
exactly what it is it went down to
effectively nothing okay and it lasted
nearly two weeks at nothing April 11 and
12 we saw a little spike very small
spike in YouTube revenue maybe about 10
percent back to our 10% of our old
revenue but then on April 13th through
April 22nd it fell off a cliff again and
we were essentially making nothing okay
so what's been going on since April 22nd
which is basically the last time we
talked about this the data I had at the
time went through April 22nd I believe
roughly plus or minus one day okay two
different measures to talk about number
one before the YouTube ad boycott we had
a 60 percent monetization rate that
meant that on average for every 10 video
views on our channel 6 ads played ok now
you as an individual might say you know
I was only getting like one ad every 10
videos or I was getting an ad on like
every video that's fine at the channel
level we were getting about 6 ads for
every 10 videos during the crisis we
were at 6 to 7% monetization which me
that we had fewer than one AD per ten
videos playing now we are at about 40%
monetization okay which is about 50 I'm
sorry
one-third less it's about two-thirds of
where we were before we used to get six
ads every ten videos now we're at four
now that might sound Pat like it's great
like we're making two-thirds of what we
were making before but it is not just
how many ads play that matters it is the
quality of the ads and this is really
where we're getting crushed before the
YouTube ad boycott there's a bunch of
different types of YouTube ads some are
called auction ads some are called
reserve ads reserve ads are the good
quality ads that pay way more auction
ads are sort of the bottom of the barrel
as the name suggests it's sort of what's
left over for advertisers to bid on when
there are not enough reserve ads to play
prior to the boycott half of our ads
were reserve ads good quality ads that
pay anywhere from 50 to 100 percent more
than auction quality ads we used to have
50 percent reserve ads we now have two
percent reserve ads two percent reserve
ads so basically we've got two thirds of
the ads that we used to have and the ads
are paying about half of what they were
so simple math multiplication of
fractions tells us two thirds times one
half equals one-third so we're basically
that what I'm getting at is we have
about a third of the YouTube revenue
back from what we had before it's not
losing 99 percent but this is still a
problem and that's why we're still
trying to raise money around it and
that's sort of what everyone was
predicting to that we wouldn't get all
of our ads back and it probably wouldn't
stay the same as it was at the very
beginning when we were losing 99% of our
ads yes it would be somewhere in the
middle there and I think the problem
with that is it's a small victory so it
may cause some channels to get content
with the amount of ground that they were
able to make up yes indeed and we are
it's not a matter of being content it's
that we need to keep making up the money
so again there's a
few things you can do to help the David
Pakman show
recover the money that we've lost number
one of course there's membership you go
to david pakman.com slash membership if
the normal rates are high for you use
the coupon code
I voted seventeen number two you go to
patreon patreon is simpler than
membership you just pledge any amount of
money you want per month a dollar two
dollars ten dollars whatever you want
patreon.com slash david pakman show
number three if you ever shop on
amazon.com
go to david pakman.com slash amazon
before you shop sends us a kickback for
everything you buy number four if you
have a YouTube red subscription watch
our videos we get a fraction of your
subscription every time you watch one of
our one of our videos and lastly you can
get david pakman show gear including
coffee t-shirts bumper stickers zip up
hoodies etc at david pakman.com slash
gear let's very quickly just check in on
how patreon is doing we had crested the
1500 patron mark at the end of april but
as often happens when a new month kicks
in and patrons are charged a lot of
people's credit cards have expired or
get declined or whatever so that has
brought us back down below the 1500
patron mark so please help us keep that
growing at patreon.com slash david
pakman show even if you can only pledge
a dollar do it and you know I'm going to
try to make these updates less more
seldom because I don't want to fatigue
the audience but we do need to talk
about what's going on with the show and
remind me what the mark is before we
have to come into the show with crazy
hairstyles so if and when we get to
2,000 patrons I will do an entire show
with my puffed up hair which I put up on
my Instagram when we get to 2,000
patrons I'm willing to do that